6 25 on your wednesday morning hey we
got a viewer question about a temporary
road sign it's this one right here and
fran writes hey on my way to work
there's a sign on di between boulder
highway and sandhill saying find
alternate route 823
but fran writes i can't find anything
online about this i need to know so i
can plan that alternate route fran it
sounds like you were headed west on di
but there is a sign with the exact same
message on the eastbound side just after
sandhill
even though my camera makes the sign
look like a studio 54 disco ball the
message is clear to drivers
desert in closed starting 8 23 21 seek
alt route
well di is closing because this bridge
is about to go away
whoa okay well as an unnamed politician
sometimes says look here's the deal as
part of the year and a half long project
to fix up the 95 515 between the
spaghetti wool and flamingo the bridge
over di is going to be rebuilt the
closure of di scheduled to last from
next monday night to late saturday night
nevada department of transportation
website dedicated to the project says
the closure is the first phase of
demolition second phase will require
another six day closure that's currently
scheduled for about a month from now we
have a link to the ndot website
i515project.com as well as possible
detours it's all on our website along
with all our driving you crazy stories
eightnewsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy thanks for writing
friend buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone something's wrapping
you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com